suck a bit of you again isn't over watch
let's talk about the last expansion pack
for our game of the year 2015 The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt blood and wine Jake
we had you on a little while ago to talk
about it that was a last week of the
week before two weeks ago yeah I don't
know yeah it was after our preview event
that yeah Bob and I both played this
game fell in like a weird embargo time
where we got you in to talk about it
early but couldn't really talk about it
um and it's out today I guess yeah I
said it for on PSN Xbox whatever for $20
cool all right so let's chew it to what
I guess you've completed it I'm guessing
you're going through a second time
already yes I finished it last week and
now I'm now that I had on PlayStation 4
I have my actual save so I can kind of
see what the differences are with us
save that I've played through cool
awesome Robbie played a bit of it as
well yeah well we had the preview
version so I got like the first what was
it two hours
we played yeah I think it's about two
hours to three hours so I've got a nice
taste of it um
but yeah all weekend I've been kind of
trying to play catch-up with hearts of
stone right I just cared whether it was
cool was that Friday they when we the
build we saw had this imp this update
that was implemented implemented last
Friday oh it all the UI stuff yeah so I
got to mess around with that and that
was really helpful to like kind of come
back in into Z to the game with Davis
yeah talk about that a little bit first
actually what is in that update what's
Rob what's in it it's like UI stuff the
map apparently like zooms are way better
and stuff yeah the map is much more
responsive I think it's there's always
like a got kind of like a second delay
with lot of that UI but regardless yeah
the map is really cool what I actually I
think I love the most is so often you're
like going back and forth into the map
but now you have like up to what 3
different types of waypoints you can set
so you can set like a boss it's like say
you run across like a really high-level
boss yeah there's alan the open you can
like mark that specific spot oh that red
skull and be like ok now i know what's
there on my flyer like three levels
exactly and so there's different types
of that so i was having a blast like
setting different like waypoints trying
to like catch up on all these quests but
the a DUI DUI in general is it's much
it's probably the best update i've seen
to that
and as far as you guy goes yeah like
they've split up like your armor and
weapons nicely right so you know
basically like differentiate uh an an
armor repair kit and a weapon right
because those are so similar I mean that
whole UI was a bit of a like they
eventually got there like with so much
of this game they eventually caught
there and that's kind of cool like they
they made good on sort of adding in like
the extra control stuff and all that and
I guess we're coming up on a year now
almost until it's added so great that we
have a second expansion pack Rob was
talking about heart to stone first
question actually with blood online do
you sort of meet tab hearts of stone
completed do you need to have the game
completed what do you think is like the
perfect time to come in to play blood
and wine so you don't need a complete
hearts of stone
I recommend it just because if you're
playing off your sort of main save it'll
kind of level you up to that point God
so you're ready for it
but I mean you don't really have to I
think thirty four is about where you
want to start on that and then in terms
of story wise you can pretty much jump
in whenever although I recommend doing
it later rather than earlier um because
of some of the endgame stuff it's
probably better just to wait but you
don't necessarily need to have like
witcher 3 like finished finished no you
do not need to have it finished i forget
the exact point where you can kind of
jump into it but I think it's probably
at the beginning of I don't spoil too
much but I got the neg fight and after a
big fight a big big fight yeah the big
fight that's all the feels like the end
of the game but then I actually see the
same four hearts of stone because
there's a couple of little spoilers that
happen sort of in that area as well
Maranda um so let's dive into it I guess
the first reader boring question gonna
ask is how long is this how big an
expansion pack is it it sounded like
they were trying to make a lot sort of
like a small little addendum to The
Witcher and after talking to some of the
CD Projekt RED folks a couple of months
back it sounded like this expansion pack
had actually gotten away from the moon
was quite big does it feel big does it
take a long time to complete so if
you're if you just want to blaze through
the story it'll probably take you about
ten hours like the story is not super
long but the area's massive there are a
ton of new quests there's a ton of new
stuff to collect like you could easily
spend 40 to 50 hours I think on Kevin
Van Orden or abuse review said he spent
40 hours and I think I'm at about 30
maybe but I'm already starting my second
run through now so by the time I'm done
I could I don't know
easily sink 50 hours into this awesome
Kevin gave it an 8 a 10 on gamespot Rob
you've only played two hours we are a
massive family witcher's any questions
you have for Jake about this like what
are the sort of things that you want to
know about yeah I know a lot of people
were on the same boat of will you be
seeing a lot of familiar characters from
the main game all right
when you actually yeah I'm gonna say too
much about this but there are some very
good new characters that they add and
there are some characters who will
return but their role isn't as big as I
hoped but then part of it too is because
the save that I played like I said was
so it was part of the advance copy like
I wasn't able to use my save and I think
if I was playing on my save when I've
tied up more of loose ends it might be
kind of different like I might see
different characters I'm trying to be as
Vegas Brian yeah even good I don't
listen
but yeah there are definitely some
surprises but you'll be spending most of
your time with Anna Henriette the
Duchess of Tucson who I think is an
excellent character there's another
character who I also won't spoil but
he's from the books I know a lot of
people when I said I wasn't gonna spoil
it like every one of the comments
figured out who it was right but I mean
it's pretty easy to figure out if you
have read the books how many of these
people can you have the sex with one
okay great all right um well well let's
just say he Jake here I would have montz
what is the sort of sex any one all he
was editing a gameplay clip something
okay I will just say it was it was a joy
to watch it was it was definitely the
most ridiculous sex scene they've had
like really oh my god yeah I mean it
wasn't like like there's still no no no
I am feel free to you know describe it
in excruciating detail you're a video
game journalist Jake so it's basically
zero gravity sex so alright [ __ ] that's
all right yeah I mean that's it video
you get we did it we did it
have you tasted it 20:16 happened May
31st
beautiful we got oh it here okay that
that's the big sex scene of the game
there might be more I haven't come
across any other sex so it doesn't come
across any hey hey okay hey so what else
is in this something oh yeah
there so you what I'm really excited is
I think like the main dry for me is
there's this whole new skill tree for
mutagens oh yeah that and when we saw
the preview bill they hinted at you know
you basically basically clean can
upgrade your art some sign to throw down
like a freezing AOE type of move have
you tried out any other ones I know
there's 12 all right so I've tried out a
few one of the big things with that is
that you need greater mutagens if you
don't know that is basically you just
need a farm mutagens in order to get
these right and then you need lots of
skill points so unfortunately with the
PC bill that I was playing I didn't get
to use a lot but I did get to you some
and the ones I did get to use were
really cool they were slightly
overpowered but I think that's the point
right this is kind of like their final
outing so it's kind of like you just
kind of have fun like one in particular
that I really liked was every time you
counter someone who's their health is
like below 25% you get an instant
finisher and the finish in this really
cool so slight oh you counter it and
garel like dodges and cuts the guy's
head off and all sorts of gory things
like that which is there's a lot of fun
sorry go ahead up which I'd like to
strip no finish or would you say that
there are some ones that you've seen
there there ones you've seen before but
the thing is is normally it was kind of
random when those would happen okay I
think there was like a certain
percentage to dismember and this it
happens no matter what so it does this
all this stuff we're talking with the
sock pull back into the main game like
if you had unfinished quests like I have
a bunch of unfinished quest in the main
game would all that mutagen stuff
without pull back into the main game as
well or is it sort of isolated so if you
have if you have blend wine then yes if
you don't have blended wine you'll still
get the new UI but you won't get the new
mutagen okay
so yeah if you complete the quest you
needed to get those mutagens then you
can go back to you can go back to
Skellig or whatever and you'll still
have all these sort of Opie mutagens at
your disposal sweet I guess the last
question on this is like as somebody who
is a big fan of this year
is like you have completed the witcher 3
how many times you've completed weld
onto this stage three okay three times
that's quite a lot it took me like the
budget errors later once and you have no
life that's fine to worry about it
as somebody who's a big fan of series
did this feel like a good sort of last
farewell are you satisfied with what it
ended up being because we know waited
almost a year for this expansion and
yeah what did you think about it so I
yeah I was very satisfied with it I kind
of like what I said before like I think
I need to replay it with my save because
some of the loose end right that may
have not been tied up in that save are
definitely tied up in my save so I kind
of like to see how the ending differs
with that but in terms of like Geralt
story I think it's a great finish take
Geralt story and I think just sort of
they take a lot of sort of liberties
with this with their final one they play
a lot of jokes I mean cuz his at the end
of the Waltons the Garrard story for you
know whatever waits it's it's kind of
wrapped up anyway right yeah so is this
sort of like a fun little jolt after the
song exactly and it kind of doesn't take
itself nearly as seriously as the main
game even though it is still very dark
but like saved by the fat bow like
something like summer break or whatever
it sort of does kind of feel like that
but I was shown Rob one place in
particular that you get to later in the
game which looks like it's taken
straight out of like a fantasy a
beautiful fantasy book yeah cool it's
absolutely gorgeous um yeah I mean it
that's what's super cool about this
expansion I would say is how much
different it looks stylized wise like
it's a very bright like I'm just having
played almost all weekend god it's like
overcast raining the whole time you know
it's like it's it's a very gloomy area
for the most part like no-man's land and
all that sort of right um but this is
the exact flip of the totem pole like it
seems like a very cool reef like
refreshing area to explore it's
excellent forward to it
20 bucks you said Jack he's 25 plus 25
you have the season pass ah God um you
get it for free if you this is a
passerine it's 20 if you don't have it
but you might as well get the season
pass I mean it's a stone as well
hearthstone was pretty good yeah you
know smaller but but definitely the
birth plan all right they go Hado to
town on grace ball calm you can check it
out yourself folks let us know if you're
going to be interested taking off to
witcher 3 and whether or not you're
happy with how that whole series ended
now in the comment box below